hi mystery Recaps here today I'm going
to explain an American superhero action
film called Ant-Man spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
[Music]
y'all ready for Ant-Man 3D y'all ready
for Scott Lang's hot Wang sticking out
of the screen at Ya let's take it back
to the origins first the opening scene
begins in 1989 with the introduction of
Hank Pym a popular physicist and
entomologist he works for the best
research facility in the world Shield
currently he has discovered magical
particles that are capable of either
shrinking or enlarging someone Hank has
even created a suit using these
particles which he believes will help
the nation fight against terrorists and
of course enable perverts however the
superiors at Shield want the technology
for their own benefit they want to
create superhumans but Hank is totally
against this so to keep the technology
from falling into the wrong hands Hank
resigns from Shield that's not how that
works if Hank developed it while working
for shield it would have belonged to
them this is Marvel's bull several years
later he establishes his own
organization Pim Technologies which he
runs with his daughter hope and a guy
named Darren Hank continues his research
but he hides the suit and its technology
even from his employees unfortunately
one day Darren gets to know about it so
he starts plotting to overthrow Hank out
of his own company after a lot of
planning he finally prevails Hank is
forced to resign and Darren is made the
new CEO of Pim Technologies in the
present day Darren calls the old man to
his office and unveils a new suit he has
recently designed he calls it Yellow
Jacket apparently this suit has all the
attributes like the one Hank had
designed back in 89 Darren is now
looking to test it on some live subjects
and if it works he will start Mass
producing it this frightens the old man
as he believes that the suit could cause
destruction if the bad guys get a hold
of it however Darren could care less he
just wants to make money money
elsewhere a convict named Scott Lang is
being released from prison after three
years in captivity he ended up in jail
after infamously burglarizing his own
employer he was also pulled over
multiple times for looking too damn sexy
Scott is picked up by his old accomplice
Lewis and on the way the latter reveals
that he is a new Heist for him however
Scott refuses to be a part of it saying
that he does not want to disappoint his
daughter anymore the following day Scott
applies to several jobs but everywhere
he is rejected due to his criminal
history this sends him spiraling into a
state of depression the only ray of
light in Scott's life is his daughter
Cassie so he goes to visit her
unfortunately his ex-wife Maggie and her
new cop husband Paxton immediately asked
him to leave Maggie warns Scott that if
he wants to see their daughter he will
have to get a decent job and make the
child support payments dejected Scott's
storms out of the house and later
calculates how much money is required
for child support when he learns that it
is a lot he reluctantly decides to join
hands with Louis and take part in the
heist in the next scene Lewis briefs
Scott about his mission in which he will
have to rob an old scientist's house
apparently there are a lot of valuables
and high-end gadgets there which would
sell for millions in the black market
that scientist is none other than Hank
Pym Scott who is a professional at such
robberies immediately accepts that night
he climbs the fence removes the window
sensors and then proceeds to the
basement by opening a window after
unlocking the basement door he finds a
second door which is fingerprint coated
fortunately Scott is prepared for such
situations he cleverly lifts the
fingerprints using some of his tricks
and finally manages to open the door
because of the intense security Scott
assumes that something very valuable is
kept inside but to his dismay all he
finds is a strange red suit he is
unaware that he is broken into Hank
pym's house who has been watching him
all along back at Pim technology Darren
is attempting to shrink a sheep to the
microscopic size unfortunately in the
process stands up killing the poor
animal
the experiment is deemed a failure but
Darren is determined to carry on with
the tests elsewhere Scott returns home
with the suit and tries it on inside the
bathroom he then presses a red button on
his hand and as soon as he does so he
suddenly shrinks to the size of an
insect to make matters worse Lewis
enters the bathroom and turns on the fap
what oh the tap creating a tsunami for
the little guy Scott desperately tries
to press the button on his other hand
hoping that it will revert him back to
his original form but to no avail so he
simply makes a run for it and ends up
falling through a crack Scott lands on
the lower floor where hundreds of people
are enjoying a party he somehow avoids
getting trampled but once again falls
through a crack and reaches another room
there he is sucked inside a vacuum
cleaner chased by a rat and launched by
a mousetrap at last he smashes through
the window and lands on top of a car the
impact finally reverts him back to his
original size confused and scared by the
incident later that night Scott decides
to go back inside the compound to return
the suit but just as he jumps inside he
is surrounded by cops Scott is arrested
and taken to jail where Paxton tells him
that he is once again disappointed his
daughter shortly after another cop
arrives and informs Scott that his
lawyer has arrived this surprises the
latter as he never contacted any lawyer
when he goes to check who it is he finds
the scientist Hank waiting for him the
Old Man reveals that he has been
monitoring Scott ever since he got out
of jail he purposely spread the rumor
that his house contained valuables so
that Lewis would be lured to it in fact
he wanted Scott to steal the suit and
try it on saying all this Hank gives
Scott two options he can either waste
his years in prison or he can embrace
the suit and work for him as Scott
returns to his cell confused an army of
ants suddenly arrives with the suit he
doesn't think twice and puts it on in
the next second he shrinks in size like
earlier Scott then escapes the prison
and outside a flying ant is waiting for
him he immediately mounts it and tries
to ride it through the streets but
because as of the high speed he feels
nauseous and passes out Get It Together
Scott you never seen a flying ant before
you [__] the next morning Scott wakes
up at Hank's house with hope and a bunch
of ants looking over him later the old
man summons him to the dining room and
reveals that he was chosen because of
his unique skill of sneaking into places
undetected Hank then tells Scott
everything about the history of the suit
and even explains how he plans to stop
Darren with it but for that he wants
Scott to go to pem technology and steal
the Yellow Jacket while he's there Scott
will have to erase all the records of
the research so that Darren can never
replicate the tech again elsewhere at
Pim Technologies Darren finally manages
to shrink a sheep to the size of an
insect hope Witnesses this and becomes
worried so she immediately informs her
dad about it meanwhile Scott believes
that the mission is too dangerous so he
advises the old man to seek help from
The Avengers however the latter refuses
saying that he doesn't want the
technology to fall into the hands of
Tony Stark he mentions that he is doing
the us for the sake of mankind and this
finally convinces Scott so he starts
training himself for the mission by
practicing martial arts and learning the
ability to control ants he also works on
his timing by shrinking and growing back
multiple times in one instance he tries
to become even smaller by altering his
suit but Hank stops him the old man
claims that if he shrinks any more he
will reach subatomic size and enter the
quantum realm where reality and the
Notions of time and space are irrelevant
you gotta wait for phase four for that
scat we gotta wait till the writers run
out of good ideas once he reaches this
realm there is no coming out of it Hank
knows all of this because in the year
1987 his wife Janet also made the same
mistake during a mission she shrunk her
size more than she should have and to
this day she has been trapped inside the
quantum realm for the first mission
Scott is asked to retrieve a piece of
equipment that he will require in the
mission the only problem is that this
equipment is guarded inside the Avengers
headquarters despite this Scott heads to
the location where he encounters the
Falcon Sam Wilson at first he politely
asks for the equipment but when the
Falcon refuses they get into a fight it
goes on for several minutes but in the
end Scott shrinks in size enters the
Falcon's suit and destroys it from the
inside and after this he retrieves the
equipment and makes a run for it later
as Hank and Scott are discussing their
next move Darren arrives there he
informs the old man that he has
successfully tested his suit and is
going to sell it to a buyer the
transaction is going to be held in a
high security building where even the
vents will be sealed with microscopic
Mash before leaving the cocky Darren
invites Hank to witness the sale I
sealed it off so you can't come in but
here's an open invite hearing all this
Scott realizes that the mission is going
to be tougher than expected so he calls
a Lewis for help but what the hell is
Lewis gonna do in the next scene the
group carries out the necessary
arrangements and gets ready to steal the
Yellow Jacket Lewis disguises as a
security officer and reduces the water
pressure inside the water pipes using
this opportunity Scott manages to sneak
inside the building along with his aunt
friends on the other hand the buyer
arrives and he is revealed to be an
executive from Hydra a notorious
underworld Corporation if the Yellow
Jacket falls into their hands Humanity
will be at a serious risk meanwhile
Scott enters the server room to plant a
bomb in the system at first he directs
his aunt friends to damage the
building's security system and burn all
backup data once that is done Scott
heads to the transaction room and
prepares to steal the Yellow Jacket
however when he lunges at it Darren
arrives in the nick of time and traps
him inside a glass cage it turns out he
was well aware of their plan and had
been tracking Scott for some time Darren
then brings out a gun and prepares to
finish Hank off but right then Scott
breaks free and unleashes a brutal
punishment on the hydra agents while
this is happening Darren shoots Hank in
the chest and then aims for Scott but
the resilient ants show up and prevent
him from pulling the trigger realizing
that he is going to be defeated Darren
somehow Retreats with the bag carrying
the yellow jacket after a while Scott
also incapacitates all the hydra agents
and goes after him meanwhile the bomb
that was planted in the server room is
about to explode so Hank gives his tank
keychain to Hope and asks her to enlarge
its size as soon as she does so the
father-daughter Duo escapes the building
right before it caves in elsewhere
Darren escapes the place in a helicopter
but soon he notices an army of ants
approaching him it turns out that Scott
was also able to board the helicopter
panicked Darren brings out his gun and
begins shooting at him but due to
Scott's tiny size none of the bullets
can act hence with no options left
Darren puts on the yellow jacket and
shrinks to the size of Scott with this
the two tiny humans start battling it
out for Supremacy soon they fall out of
the helicopter and land in a pool but
the fighting doesn't stop there Scott
somehow manages to throw Darren into a
light bulb and electrocute him but just
when he is about to finish the bad guy
off Paxton arrives and arrests him
Paxton's [__] his wife and his plans
after they are gone Darren wakes up and
decides to exact Vengeance on Scott by
going after his family meanwhile as
Paxton is leading Scott to the police
station he is informed that someone is
broken into his house wasting no time
the two head there and discovered Darren
holding little Cassie hostage this
enrages Scott so he once again shrinks
in size and starts fighting the bad guy
but no matter how hard he tries Darren
keeps repelling his attacks this is when
Scott realizes that in order to defeat
the yellow jacket he will have to get
inside of it by shrinking himself even
further he knows that there is no coming
back but for the sake of his daughter's
safety he proceeds with the plan it
works and as soon as Scott enters the
suit he destroys it from inside causing
Darren to vanish Into Thin Air but with
this Scott also gets trapped in the
quantum realm there is nothing but an
endless vacuum around him he tries using
the button on his hand but it doesn't
work right then he hears his daughter
crying and this gives him the motivation
to get out of the place he recalls the
equipment that he had stolen from The
Avengers base and uses it to rewire his
suit surprisingly this works I don't
know how but it works and he is able to
return to the normal World Scott
immediately Embraces his daughter and at
the same time the cops also arrive
however seeing his bravery Paxton covers
for him giving him ample time to shrink
in size and Escape in the final scene
Hank and Scott are having a conversation
about the events that transpired last
night the old man is still in shock as
to how Scott was able to escape the
quantum realm however he is now hopeful
that his wife can also be brought back
the movie ends as Lewis catches up with
Scott and reveals that the Avengers are
looking to recruit him subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching